what kind of car do you drive I drive a
Prius yeah of course you do you don't
you're not into fossil fuels you're an
amphibian that doesn't uh believe in
fossil fuels that's right yeah hey you
don't believe in fracking or natural gas
or any of that stuff you're not you you
just want to put people out of those
jobs what are you going to tell them
learn to code I was just looking for
cheap gas mileage dude yeah one time I
took mushrooms with uh Mike Tyson oh and
uh Chris Carter the guy who invented the
guy who created that show The X Files
and uh we saw the mark of the beast no
yeah 30 feet high speaking to us and
everyone around the globe at the at the
exact same time sounds like a good time
it was a good time I like to get loose
do you like uh do you like uppers or
downers what kind of a guy are you